another key takeaway i think is this
idea that um
which is actually an old idea around
circle of competence or understanding
where you have an edge and where you
don't and electing to play the games
that you can win uh and you think you
can win over and over and over again
because of your edge versus not uh is
this something that almost every great
investor has or is it possible for a
great investor actually to go into
markets where they don't have an edge
and because they're a great investor a
great thinker they can be successful
i think pretty much without exception
the the great investors i've met have
this tendency to to stick to games that
they specifically can win and and this
was something it came through to me very
clearly when i spent time with ed thorpe
who um
is is was not only an extraordinary
hedge fund manager who who um didn't
have a losing quarter in 20 years with
his hedge fund but also
figured out how to count cards and beat
the casino at blackjack he was kind of
the the inventor of card counting as i
understand it then figured out how to
beat the casino at roulette so here's a
guy who's the who's the ultimate game
player and and he said to me look if i
don't have an edge i don't play
and
so when i talked to him about about this
question i said to him well so how can i
tell if i have an edge and he said well
if you don't have a rational reason to
think that you have an edge then you
almost certainly don't and that for me
was quite unsettling because i started
to think well so
when it comes to buying individual
stocks for example do i have an edge
and i'm pretty certain that i don't i
mean it's pretty clear to me
that i don't have the best temperament
for this that i don't necessarily have
the technical knowledge but i don't have
the patience to analyze balance sheets
and the like i'm not that interested in
in in in going through the numbers
really patiently and seeing whether
whether there's a discrepancy or a lie
or something in the footnote him that's
just not what interests me and so that
for me was a really profound realization
just to learn
from eds or bouquets so if i don't have
an edge at this particular game picking
individual stocks
let me just not play that game that's
not a game that i'm likely to win and so
occasionally i violated it and i i
violated it again a couple of weeks ago
and bought an individual stock and and
it kind of tortures me because i'm aware
that it's an irrational and stupid thing
for me to do that i'm much better off
just giving the money to someone else
who's who's better equipped to win that
game and and so for for your listeners i
i just think that's an incredibly
important idea of sticking to games that
you're equipped to win
and and avoiding games that you're
really not equipped to win and it sounds
so obvious but most of us don't do it
and and so what's really striking is how
many of the great investors end up
telling you no no you should just index
and
that in a way is the most rational thing
for most of us to do howard mark says
most investors should index most of
their money and so part of my default
position in investing my own money is
that i i own a couple of index funds
because i i sort of figure i should try
not to delude myself into thinking this
is a game i'm likely to win but then i
also figure i spent 25 years
interviewing many great investors and so
so i do figure i might have some edge in
terms of picking good fund managers
because
um because i know a lot of them and so
it's possible that i have an edge there
and so i i do own about three actively
managed funds but i think that again is
a really good filter of just asking
yourself
do i have a rational reason to believe
that i have an edge
and let me let me stick to games in
which i do have an edge
what's up guys bang bang it's your boy
pomp thanks so much for watching the
best business show our goal is to make
this the largest most actionable
business show in the world and to do
that we need your help we've partnered
with sofi as our exclusive sponsor
because they have a piece of software
that we think will help you take the
information that we share on a daily
basis and make it actionable we want
every single person to pursue and
achieve financial security and financial
freedom in order to do that you gotta
act and sofi allows you to do it so you
can go to
sofi.com today you can open up an
account and when you open up an account
you can invest in all sorts of different
types of assets etfs individual stocks
ipos bitcoin cryptocurrencies they even
have an automated investing function if
you want to invest sofi can help you
they've got a couple of different offers
that you can benefit from the first open
an invest account and they'll give you
up to a thousand bucks for free kind of
a no-brainer second is if you go on and
you buy one of the cryptocurrencies that
they offer they'll go ahead and they'll
give you ten dollars of bitcoin for free
and third some of you are saying i
already have a brokerage account i
already have an account somewhere else
right now you can get up to five
thousand dollars for transferring your
account that's right so far doesn't care
where your current account is but if you
transfer it from that place to sofi
they'll pay you up to five thousand
dollars for doing it why wouldn't you do
it it's up to five thousand dollars for
free head on over to sofi.com today to
get started and come back tomorrow and
watch more of the best business show
together we're gonna build the biggest
show in the world
[Music]
you